now to the latest on gas prices that are
going only one way right now and that's
up the national average for a gallon of
regular is now
4.96 that's nearly 30 cents higher than
last week carter evans is in los angeles
where gas is a lot more expensive than
that carter good morning
a lot more expensive at an average of
639 a gallon a round trip from la to san
francisco is going to cost you about 250
dollars now right now it is cheaper to
fly there than it is to drive there and
those sky-high prices are expected to
keep rising
with no relief in sight of the gas pump
americans are digging deeper into their
pockets
another job just to pay for gases
and it just keeps getting more expensive
as countries turn away from russian oil
limiting global supplies but those
eye-popping prices at the pump still
aren't scaring away summer travelers
according to oil analyst tom klosa how
high is it going to have to get before
people actually really pull back on
driving well that's an experiment in
progress right now but my sense is is
that people are still going to take
vacations the high demand could drive
the national average to five dollars a
gallon within weeks enough to push some
people to give up gasoline for good all
electric vehicles i cannot keep them in
stock for more than
two hours
that fast goes that quick yes
kia is the second biggest seller of
electric vehicles behind tesla the
company's ev sales are up 132 percent
from last year electric with some money
sounds like a no-brainer these days
at a senate hearing tuesday treasury
secretary janet yellen warned lawmakers
that painted the pump could continue
it's virtually impossible for us to
insulate ourselves from shocks like the
ones that are occurring
in russia
that move global oil prices another wild
card hurricane season about 50 percent
of the nation's refining capacity is
along the gulf coast if a hurricane hit
and knocked 10 percent of our refining
capacity offline what would that do but
i think a hurricane really alters the
calculus then you get into the six to
seven dollar a gallon range
so when are we going to get some relief
well the news there is not so good most
analysts don't think we'll see gas back
in the three dollar a gallon range well
at least this year but there are two
things that could drive prices back down
very quickly one is another coveted wave
the other well no one wants to see a
recession
dana
yeah carter this after some record
profits for oil companies in the first
quarter even thank you